so it was a say when 91 I was about
maybe 12 12 13 and I'm 18 Union it's you
know Union going down and eight then
Wilshire we're gonna get you know we'll
get some breakfast in the morning at
that Chinese food land and uh we always
get chicken and we all like spread like
here's one for you one for you one for
you we look it up and everything
hello bowl of rice and uh no go you know
start slinging and uh you know our
enemies or any given moment and back in
the 90s it was like you know you know
the hell was your game
pah-pah-pah don't be shooting well it
was one of them days where I didn't
think it would and all right here's oh
you know it's joking I quo and all the
homies just gone quick huh as I'm trying
to take you know leave from you know the
spot where Wars hot I spoke II turn
around
oh no I go to homie he goes tell me tell
me i'm okay i k my boy or my boy a
cha-cha chill out chill out chill out
charge you know someone call that with
one handle phone dan when you come down
from number one not no one around but
someone [ __ ] called 9-1-1 just
hanging in there with a homie i just you
know look what just conversate with him
motivate him gonna be okay he's he's
bleeding from his mouth you're like
looking out late don't look anything
like she gonna be alright
you know I'm gonna say dad is it too
much for me or he's going through too
much they say how you know um emmalin
showed up you know when i'm asked him on
his face you see the little you know
he's breathing
no hard relief there okay are you late
um that's
I miss Ren you know his mom and dad know
we have no idea this bin
we have no idea I can't really uh
I can I got go let the parents know well
then we'll do that because you know you
can troll only unrelated family members
no I understand
so stepfather you know em listen avenues
took my home Bridget oh uh General
Hospital here we are is you know huh
we have no right so what we do take the
bus watch bus we're gonna give I don't
know this we're all fighting for the bus
man take this walk with it don't buy the
damn River bedding and the mission to
sell away straight down there oh come on
man yep here we are like little little
rascals out there going out there do you
know to see if the homies okay yeah well
we all get to General Hospital almost at
2:00 3:00 in the morning the security
and doctors like Menominee we were like
at least seven of us and we answer is it
Homer okay who's your who's your wait uh
you know I'm out my homeboy sporty and
he's us we don't know no sporty and one
of the homies home for his real name it
was yeah yeah yeah yeah I hold on it
the nurse called the dog you know to
call the thing and then there's heard
from other nurse tell him you know where
he was at okay and she goes is his mom
and dad are here
this is when I say lie no they're not
they're not here but we're home
you know worst friends if you wanna know
he's okay I can't get this information
out basically you're just telling me
that he's you know but as a king you
know I mean you know Here I am gonna
play guess who like well now we got to
call them and I don't know the number
but she couldn't tell me the information
that what I don't want to hear but not
even within twenty minutes later the mom
and dad show up when they show up they
look at me and all the homies in which
one of you this to my son
we were I was scared like a [ __ ] you
know I mean kids won't say I wasn't
around for my hood and I'm a you don't
let it hold me down
bad enough you passed away gang banging
don't get shot don't get stabbed slow
your roll huh it's part of the game
I'm afraid from that no one to get
killed but hey you know what time it is
you know I can't get soft on this like
in this game [ __ ] but the reality of is
seeing the family just break down thank
God that wasn't you do you think that
now cuz you're benching going hey yeah
on your stripes right life in tears in
just days gonna be okay
damn I wish I was that easy as a kid huh
you know huh on the next one my own
homeboy [ __ ] dome I'm at the park
we're playing handball two of the homies
that we even know up or just playing it
playing good games at that sanitary
Springs by the river be right there
laughs a freeway Ferguson beers we're
cookies and beer to having a good time
fun with the gold days youngsters any
book man we're just doing the damn thing
and as you play the game and almost
briefings from you here at once you're
playing the games on the ball pop and
pop you know you're doing it you know he
get a good rally but you promised it now
I'm thinking it's like it's another game
called the party probably something else
up and I ask you again wait whoa put the
ball hit wants to boil it twice that's
my boy that's my point
you didn't hear that he's more about the
game that I heard but they click on the
wrong page I turn around to look that
girls already facing him ah ah [ __ ] up
the homeboy just goes down pulled
backwards home was a come on fool I'm
gonna chase him with the gun dig or if I
can't be with the home in right there
this is to me is this Chapter two but
this one a fool I'm all right I'm all
right
hey you know you had a phone call
nine-one-one no not me no let's go for
it
he had low budget car you drive I got
you you want to go to the house
why for what he wonder well the house
because he want to get the gun I roll
with him get the gun
I'm not the stupidest man but he looks
like he's getting a little more like
slower I'm come on homeboy but he wants
it you know he's older than me but still
but my point is like you know save his
life I fight him you put anything a
spokes don't even do that only just come
on and say come on just just do it well
when we got into the car and the homeboy
goes as potion I got this homeboy just
put his head down just went down that
part right there I knew when he's put
his head down I know he was gone
I can't bring know about the life I know
that the bullet go it got someone inside
knows you know they're saying is the
first time it's it's a bad memory and
the second time only makes you stronger
if the first one didn't bring you down
the second was that make you like now
you know why I don't want to go there
now I don't want to do that now you
don't have to do it it comes to you
you're playing a ball once again why
didn't put the gun at me wasn't my time
on the last one 14 years old mom way
also
my home who also wanted you know to
prove a point
yeah you know and he's down for his hood
I don't have a problem with that I know
you're down on I know you're down I know
I know you know you don't rank up for
nothing homes sometimes you gotta
[ __ ] but all you got into it just
don't that you know you are the bug on
also you are the homie right there
I was brought up by beam drills Fame
real don't be fake if you had nothing
good to say don't say anything at all
but I was always ready to race with
respect
what's respect huh we need people
telling people yes please no thank
excuse me bless you it just hurts when a
homie gets killed in front of you and
you have to be the one to tell the
family what happens that [ __ ] is so hard
dude to see the mama don't know what
Atticus loved you and the day grabs you
by the throat oh boy at the funeral I
still pick my respects like I wish that
was me I should be right there with you
but no be the smart one home you know
get a life get a life I only gets better
right yeah but sure does
I was in downtown LA and uh what am I
one of my rival enemies was you know
18th Street and uh you know a female
that look at it like you know who she
turned out that you know her name was
Cisco rest in peace and how we hooked up
we hooked up you know I mean in now
she's like where you're from until Ross
trauma orphans orphans like what I know
your homeboy song song song song ok cool
I say you know we enemies but she's a
plan I don't even trip come on let's go
follow me all right cool let's go
hanging out you know I'm doing the thing
with in downtown Lane as we're walking
she wants to take a little shortcut I'm
like hey hold hold hold up you know I
mean you go there I can go there
come on come on come on I'm like nah
it's good let's go the other way she
insisted man come on hurry about it's ok
there's no one around it seemed too easy
just to just listen to what you said and
it was like midnight as I follow her we
go down the side street in downtown on
and my neighborhood on 18 Union as I'm
walking through my my name my enemy's
neighborhood it was Whitmer it was a
side street by the hotel as we're making
a left it was like an intersection of
two streets and houses as I turn with
her in the middle all I hear is oh look
hey almost were you from what I see
three fools jumped the fence
oh I see fools come on the building what
I see su code upstairs oh [ __ ] so homie
it's a home away from I see more than 15
people came oh my god so any hit me
what's up were you from here she goes
Cisco they hold the hood up she's in
front of me and he's oh he's with me
he's with me I'm like hey don't go I'm
watching my I'm watching my surroundings
they surround me I can't run I'm gonna
dead-end and when they rushed me when
they found out where I was from when
they rush me they punched
her she went down and I'm fine I'm
trying to hit two or three people legs
arms kick me I went down and when I went
down my head hit the concrete bone pull
I'm like oh the rubbing my head in the
street I'm like oh and they're kicking
me stomping me I'm just like god help me
all I hear was a one time boom they let
go the altar of me they all skelewu
cucarachas I got up I got up of mice
I said out loud [ __ ] just mad she's like
she's exposure okay shut the [ __ ] up I
was so mad and I was in tears just get
the [ __ ] away from me I walked away and
I'm going to my uncle's house when he
was at throwing on seventh in Garland he
was a manager I'm walking I'm limping I
got blood coming down walking to them
I'm walking to is this place
a deal who is it it's me it's me smokey
hold on opens the door lets me in what
the hell's wrong with you man I got had
blood I try to wash myself up I was so
much in pain I say man is this how it
really goes down he goes what happened I
told her that I went with Cisco to dildo
shortcut for bender ha this man for you
know for not paying attention see what
happens
I says damn man I'm like I don't get
killed because you're lucky I didn't
kill you
I said man I was just man I'm telling
you man it is beyond crazy to survive
when you got 15 people on you they want
to kill you because you know it's part
of the game you get caught sleeping you
get killed you know there was another
time in my neighborhood 18 Union you
know we were all about seven all of us
from Orange County and LA all pulls up
with right there by Union just post it
up you know just this in the radio and
everything there enough come down the
street and [ __ ] you know [ __ ] our
neighborhood like all right all right
whatever about turn around what's the
pitch man what's up man man shine them
on sure enough man we look at one two
one seven eight fools man fools got a
damn on the club thing for the cars
fool had him uh uh what is thankful had
a bat so let's get down I said hey I
wish I homies oh man
they brought their note man when we went
at it with these fools these fools were
swinging we're moving away we're like
whoa watch it was swing at my home I
gets here in the back pull my Seng what
the hell I sweet that crowbar its waves
boom hit again the face foam was a year
I go down bombing on the bottom guy hits
me the bed with a crowbar boom I get
cracking back in my skull I'm like down
we're fighting we're all bloody and
funny sit with a lap or Xenopus yeah I
don't know what is now late Batman when
the surroundings see shits going down
they always stayed up we see them you
see ain't no meaning everyone just kind
of walked away my homeboy was up and
limping I grabbed him get him up come on
my boy I said man this was gangbang is
all about with me I should I mean I
cannot tell you anymore but I mean [ __ ]
you know you know me myself in and my
gangbanging days I was you know I was I
was serving and you know it was one of
these nights where I had I was almost
like I was by myself in my neighborhood
not one of the balconies and it turned
out this one paisa because one paisa
came down and when he came down he came
down ain't gonna compromise the atom you
wanna buy some material I go
quantitative and I go hey dualism
policia come on
I'm not a priest yeah I said well what's
up man what do you I mean let me see man
y'all pick up a shirt hey I wanna buy
some rock all right homie how much wanna
buy it I won't bite she went off with
the rock 200 oh okay alright hold on
hold up
you know me so I kind of played off him
not knowing I had I had I had a shot
behind my back you know I mean it was it
was Ella I was a 38 you know only what
what may 14 14 or 15 and this guy wanna
buy material but he look really get a
sweater on a t-shirt
sweating yeah like medium haircut he
just look rule
just like rules like it was just real
stinky and he insisted come on where's
it okay homie hold on well back then our
material was in foil wrapped up you know
you have to open up like this in the
falls inside and hey come on come on I
said hold on hey where's the money out
it goes let me see hey this guy pulls
out a machete and I look like whoa give
me a holdover and when he swung I hear
that damn machete goes I said hold on
I'm looking around not one of my
homeboys is around I'm by myself and he
insisted one of my time right kill you
I'm gonna kill you hold up hold up hold
up you want it you want it right here as
as he's looking Never Knows I'm not as
I'm looking I threw it to him his eyes
follow it up and eyes look down when his
eyes looked down oh man was aren't you'd
rush him with a machete try to be a hero
and like that I mean he didn't know but
it was off safety I mean I did it then
smart thing I threw it up he followed it
and when I 21 when his eyes hit the
ground the machete was not even length
understood to hit me
and when he looked when I when he lifted
it and looked go down ice lean back I
grabbed it like I'm not gonna fall back
Oh boom hey flew once hit side of his
head took Huff almost half of his head
and he goes down his knees and he falls
down and I'm just like I gotta get out
of here I gotta get out of here
as I'm running I'm running from downtown
LA my boys in South Central
I kid you not me I'm down who knows what
medication I was on some drugs I
straight went from Broadway and took
Broadway all the way down running
running kid you not
I had my strap on me when I was running
so much my whole body was just oily just
shiny I was taking up my shirt oh so hot
cops on the other side of the island
we're driving look once looked was like
who's that guy right there didn't you
pull me over as I get to my boys pad
they're like what's wrong with you so
out of breath and it turned out that hey
what happened
I explained him what happened hey well
let's go back humming don't trip on trip
you know I mean I took care of it well
we're the homies at there to say I was
by myself you know there's times in my
life where I thought I had my homeboys
to get my back sometimes you got him
sometimes you don't but what I learned
this gang banging since I was 12 years
old till now is that you're worth it or
you're not and when someone soldiers
take someone's life they want to
hesitate and they'll take your life like
that and you're through and it was so
sad about it as people walk away like oh
he's dead I'm gone yeah you didn't want
to help him look at like damn like man
it's a cold world when I came out of
prison and I found out that you know my
girl was killed in a drive-by I
investigated that [ __ ] and what I
investigated to find out who who you
know who you know who did the drive-by
turned out 18th Street okay what are the
odds our triple og slacks grade 3 color
3 color low card red shirt grey hair
mustache trim the hell is it what's this
going here there goes a Holmes you're
spooky well who are you homes
hey pick up his shirt and had the 1-800
me oh you're the wrong neighborhood on
me hey hey you know I want to talk to
you Holmes I heard what happened to lady
give me my lady on me what's up
I mean I mean because they I mean I I
could relate to what happened to your
lady but my laid out of cancer what is
that gonna do with me Holmes because the
home is that did that were stupid
the home we should have done that
because they hit a six-year old boy and
that was uncalled for that little boy
survived and then we heard about your
lady and a friend got killed too in the
drive-by damn so when he told me about
who did it of his homeboys I go back
right in my homeboys a fooi come on back
me up back here plant your loud dog
chill out on me it's alright dog will
get that I was so pissed off and not one
of them wanna help me man they look at
me like are you such a feeling me ain't
like [ __ ] you fools hey how many if it
was your lady I got killed oh you think
what help me and you mind even my
neighborhood I was breaking tears I was
so mad I went out of my building went
into a parking lot
have some Cristal I had a syringe I slam
me a shot like I want to kill myself
that shot was way too much where I
thought I should have died
pop by the grace of God guy goes it's
not your time that shot hit me so hard
breathing so hard dad why don't you kill
me why can I so what happened was I
strapped my thinking I'm gonna do it
myself I'm going to their neighborhood
how am I do it as I'm walking an old man
with a shopping cart little bum AG I
mean I long that launch in school man
and he goes right
oh man yeah I got crack all right no
problem it's got the [ __ ] told me you
put it on me Oh stinky but I mean you
know I mean I put it on me
Thompson crack man let me but okay I'll
be right here man habit man whatever
cool again what he wanted in the
shopping cart was a newspaper a little
radio some bottles whatever as I'm
riding it I'm riding it like this on a
shopping cart like that I thought like
I'm drunk whatever I'm just the trench
coat without weather with the collar up
and I'm just like that I like here here
I I hear I hear bumping turns out right
there and right there in the
neighborhood on Alvarado by the donut
shop right there it had four doors open
and that guy was cleaning his car two
ladies were on top of the porch like I
was clean his car and three others
homeboys right there
and all of sudden when they see when
they hear the noise of the cart I'm
making that noise with another loud
noise at the shopping cart hey hey get
out of here
what sure enough here they come back man
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
man hey get this one called my
neighborhood on the wrong with the scene
ever neighborhood they were trying to
Punk a bum if you think about it they
kicked the cart the cart falls over they
bumped me like that I liked with it with
a Elwell's boom I fall down
Oh their car they kick over the radio
the bottles are rolling on the street
you know I mean man get the [ __ ] out of
here man [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
the cult when it fell down
it kind of just lit up so they couldn't
see my face huh the guy was clean the
car helped me get over here ready maybe
fool oh man [ __ ] come on get over
here man come on
always Flynn turn around all right all
right right huh as soon as he turned
around and we're walking back I could
pull my thing out and I just started
stuffing oh oh the girls started
screaming aah
the guy's window he was cleaning window
just shattered guy over the back pool ah
boom I'm hitting him I'm hitting him I
let the whole clip go oh oh boom boom
like that they got down the guy though
watch the car he got away but there's m3
that came over you trying to Punk me
they went down
when I ran from downtown I had to go
back to downtown central what is a South
Central I have one of my homies down in
south central that was always he was my
partner man he was always there for me
but in a situation like that I'm just
thankful today that you know I don't got
a murder charge it just that some [ __ ]
that goes down it was just like you know
my own homeboys a dog it's on the
neighborhood homes you know a you know
it would happen
hey you know you know you know how it is
why what you know something got blasted
for real play stupid damn what happened
you know you know all it is I've got
putting work
Oh put in work on Oh i sat there as they
trying to take credit for something that
they didn't do when I know what I did
it's always good to know what you do but
then don't spread your business out
there keep it to yourself you learn
something you know I mean you know it's
just that in my life that what I've been
doing I've been through a lot of
experiences and I'm just trying to tell
taking it one day at a time and this was
six years being out of prison I think
after that I'm not trying to go
backwards I will forward thank you very
much thank you
you
you